une fête de village s'est transformée en
une attaque mortelle et un adolescent de
16 ans a été tué ce samedi dans la Drome
ça s'est passé dans la salle des fêtes
de la commune de crépool dans la nuit du
18 au 19 novembre alors que 400
personnes étaient réunies pour un bal
d'hiver des individus non identifiés ont
pénétré dans la salle communale vers 2h
du matin les auteurs qui ont quitté les
lieux avant l'arrivée des gendarmes ont
tué un adolescent à coup de couteau et
blessé près de neuf autres personnes
dont deux sont actuellement en urgence
absolue Thomas 16 ans était venu faire
la fête avec ses amis et a été tué d'un
coup de couteau c'était un nounours trop
gentil un petit gassçant histoire avec
un grand sourire a expliqué un proche de
la famille o Figaro une minute de
silence a été observée ce matin pour ce
passionné de rugby membre du club de
roman péage à roman sur iser que dire
face à la barbarie et la tragédie qui
nous touche ce matin le club est touché
dans sa chair en ce 19 novembre si une
enquête a été ouverte pour déterminer
les motivations des auteurs pour
l'instant inconnu la piste du règlement
de compte semble privilégiée selon le
procureur de la République c'était un
bain de sang les jeunes de cité ont
encerclé la salle des fêtes et plantter
les gens à l'aveugle le videer s'est
fait trancher les doigts on faisait un
massage cardiaque qu' un jeune par terre
c'était le chaos la mère de crpool a
également réagi à ce drame ce n'est pas
normal qu'il se passe des choses comme
ça dans nos petits villages ruraux c'est
un drame que nous vivons notre village
est bien affecté par cet événement c'est
de la violence gratuite ça a été très
brutal et très
violent